you know when you go to the doctor's
office just for something as simple as a
checkup
you have to sign in and then you have to
wait a while 20 30 minutes more you read
a magazine you listen your iPod anything
to kill the time it's usually a pretty
long way but there's a lot of people
that wait a lot longer than you and I do
for a checkup and it's for something
much much more important you feel sort
of hollow and you know is anyone going
to come along Sally satel knows what
it's like to wait for new life in the
form of a kidney transplant she thought
she'd found a donor several times but
one after another fell through one was a
close friend I thought she was going to
do what she thought she was going to do
it but oddly she was actually talked out
of it by a friend of hers who was a
transplant surgeon the waiting continued
until a rather unexpected someone came
forward I think I'd only seen her maybe
five or seven times in person we weren't
really close she ran into a mutual
friend I said so how Sally and she it
went well she's alright which is
obviously she's not alright I don't know
my goodness what what's up and within
three days she wrote me an email that in
the subject line said serious offer I
said you know I hear that you need a
kidney and if I'm compatible you know
I'd be willing to be a donor for you in
2006 Virginia posture L gave Sally her
right kidney and now she's my heroine
unfortunately happy endings like this
are pretty rare I've died three times
actually but they kicked me out of
heaven they didn't want me there
my grandpa sent me back one time my
cousin sent me out back the other time
the other time my dad gave me CPR had a
seizure right there on the floor like 75
thousand other Americans christina de
Lyonne doesn't have a living donor
I'm dwell on it like well that happened
to have it do what I can while I'm here
like so many others she's on a waiting
list to get a kidney from a dead person
I've been on the list since 2003 so how
long is that three four five six six
years almost
the motion effect of me waiting really
just get tired you know sometimes just
get tired but then what can you do about
it what can we do about it since
becoming a donor pass trellis thought a
lot about how to increase the supply of
kidneys there are really a lot of
misconceptions about what is involved in
kidney donation the the biggest one and
one that seems very commonsensical is
that you have two kidneys for a reason
lastrella is an author and former editor
of M Reason magazine do you live just as
well with one kidney as with two and the
transplant procedure is safer than you
might think we've never had a kidney
donor death at all program here dr.
Gabriel danovich is medical director of
the kidney and pancreas transplant
program at UCLA it's approximately the
same as the death rate after having an
appendix ectomy but each year about
3,000 americans died while on the
waiting list every year every day the
list gets larger every day someone like
you waits for an organ donation while
life passes by we passed laws we urge
people to become donors the DMV asked us
to become organ donors when we get
driver's licenses so will you how only
you have so much has been trying but the
supply of kidneys still is inadequate
people I don't know where they would
ever be adequate to keep up with the
number of people because there are so
many people in this country with
diabetes and high blood pressure and all
the other things that set people up to
develop advanced kidney disease we've
got to find a better way otherwise
patients face death or dialysis dialysis
time
come on get up Monday Wednesday Friday I
get up to go to dialysis you know 4:30
ice news till 4:45 and sometimes I get
up at time 100 each session is about 4
hours long the dialysis machine cleans
Kristina's blood doing the job a healthy
kidney would do without dialysis
patients would die with it they
deteriorate slowly nearly half won't
live 8 years
Kristina dreams of traveling you can't
just go but the 3 day a week ritual
makes it very hard you have to call a
dial the center make sure they have room
for you some places don't take people
who travel you know they call them
transients it's also tough to work
full-time I can't work at a doctor's
office because they want someone 8 to 5
they want someone in the mornings so I
can't do that because I have to a
dialysis with a new kidney Cristina
wouldn't have to be tethered to a
dialysis machine you know so much has
been tried to help people like Cristina
but there's one thing we can't try
because it's illegal stay with me
paying people to donate their kidneys I
know it sounds really cool --is-- sounds
really icky but through your kidneys and
it really helps people in need so if you
want to sell one why not
the most straightforward approach would
be simply to repeal the federal law that
makes it a crime to sell organs but
danovich says that would be a dreadful
mistake because they don't care about
each other he says money would take the
caring out of the donor recipient
relationship we're going to take the
caring out of it and it's become matter
of paying off people but pastro points
out the donors are the only ones in the
transplant process who aren't
compensated the surgeons are paid that
people it's a supply that medicines are
paid the people who clean the floors and
the hospitals are paid everybody's paid
but not the donors but would people be
less likely to help others if money were
involved voluntary donors actually feel
good about themselves pay donation
actually is a subversive at a process
that actually undermines voltage'
donation think of you know soldiers or
firefighters we respect their service
we appreciate their heroism but we also
paid for their work many worried that
the poor would be exploited who is it
that are going to be donors they're
likely to be people whose life has gone
poorly and they are in trouble
what if donors use the money to buy a
house or pay off debt should that
concern us
I don't know that paying off a debt for
I don't know child support what's wrong
with that why should we say that poor
people aren't allowed to take advantage
of being able to be kidney donors the
2002 movie Dirty Pretty Things depicts a
black market organ selling ring in
London where the rich simply buy kidneys
from the desperately poor in this scene
an immigrant nearly dies after he
exchanges his kidney for British
citizenship he swapped his insights for
a bus but some people sidestep the
waiting list in real life by becoming
transplant tourists people who have gone
abroad to buy kidneys there is by the
way a high incidence of infectious
complications the problem is not that
people are getting paid is that they're
getting defrauded and they're not
getting adequate medical care and this
is a huge problem leak Rosetta has
admitted that he was part of a scheme to
steal body parts from corpses making
something illegal isn't exactly the same
as stopping it from happening more than
1,000 stolen body parts were sold to
hospitals for transplants and other
procedures today the average wait for a
kidney is 5 years but that's expected to
nearly double as soon as the year 2010
so is there a country where selling
kidneys is legal well yes
Iran has a system of paid kidney
donation we don't have a lot of good
data but evidence suggests that many of
those donors are very dissatisfied yes
well we usually don't associate Iran
with compassion and health care they
don't feel good about themselves their
lives have not really been improved the
money they got did not really solve
their problem a new study finds problems
with the Iranian system but the author
himself a kidney specialist also
discovered that payment succeeds in a
very important way Iran is the only
nation in the world with no waiting
lists for kidneys this is one reason
that I would want it to happen in the
u.s. mistral says the US can help people
like Kristina by combining the payment
senta with our high standards for
healthcare if you look at the way people
are screened to be transplant donors you
would have much better results here if I
was rich I would pay somebody in a
heartbeat but that's not my situation
but post rel says insurance companies or
maybe even the government would pick up
the bill after all the government
already pays for dialysis this is an
enormous expense the federal government
could pay ninety to a hundred thousand
dollars per kidney and still save the
taxpayers money besides saving the life
you could get paid if that's the way you
have to go to get people off the list
because people are not donating then by
all means pay them please what would it
be like to have a transplant god it
would be heaven but I would be able to
sleep late later than the forelock you
know and we're able to eat what I want
and drink what I want and travel you
know I want to go to Indianapolis to
visit one of my best friends and I mean
it's just I'd be able to I guess it
would just be frito don't just be
freedom so what do you think it's not
such a horror movie thing after all is
it how can we end the way for people
like Christina and help give them the
freedom that they deserve for reason TV
I'm drew Carey thanks for watching
you